how Katie and Taylor turned their six
year long nasty feud into a music video
happy meal swish you need to calm down
moment with Perry is riling up fans and
we have exclusive behind-the-scenes
details on how the frenemies finally
squash their beef not a chance because
Katie may have been wearing beef but she
can Taylor have officially said - there
are six years off so how did this happy
meal come to be well according to our ET
source Katie wanted to take part in the
inclusive anthem because they're both on
the same page when it comes to LGBTQ
rights the source adds it was Katie's
idea to wear her Met Gala afterparty
hamburger dress et has learned Taylor
personally reached out to not just Katie
but all of the 29 stars who appeared in
the video all of them are LGBTQ icons
and allies including Laverne Cox RuPaul
the queer eye guys and Billy Porter who
also has a new single called love
yourself today he gave us a major
behind-the-scenes secret about Hal
Taylor doubled everybody's hectic
schedules my schedule has been so busy
with shooting post season - she sent her
people to me and we did it in front of
the green screen and some of the celeb
appearances featured what could be
hidden clues about Taylor's next album
lover there is Ellen getting a tattoo
from Adam Lambert that says real summer
mini fans think and that will be one of
the song title a could cruel summer be a
reference to the fallout off her 2016
relationship with Tom Hiddleston
ready for it
Tom got absolutely skewered for wearing
an I heart ts shirt at her fourth of
July bash and you know who else was
there that we can't cry in Reynolds and
he makes a cameo in the video as an
artist and if your freezer look closely
Ryan is painting the Manhattan gay
landmark Stonewall Inn on Friday Taylor
made an appearance during the AEG Pride
celebration she sang with Modern
Family's Jesse Tyler Ferguson and what
do you know he's also in the video
recreating his 2013 ITU's with husband
Justin Makita today he tweeted quote
just a Makita and I loved getting
married again and your playground of
fabulousness
[Music]